the second attack in just two days
another wave of missiles from Moscow
Ukraine's commander-in-chief has said 20
Rockets were fired into the country and
12 of them were shot down
the wreckage hitting residential areas
across Kiev a hotel in the center of
town and here a neighborhood in shock
they're just clearing the rubble now
this house was hit by the wreckage of a
missile fired into cave today now
there's an ongoing investigation and
Emergency Services keep pouring in to
find out if there have been any
fatalities or casualties this is a very
densely populated area in the center of
the city just by the railway station and
the impact of the glass can be felt in
broken windows and broken windshields
all around Oksana hid in her basement
while her home shook from the blast she
came out to find the house across the
street in Ruins
foreign
earlier today Putin delivered his
longest New Year address to date at a
military headquarters in a southern city
he accused the west of lying to Russia
and provoking Moscow to launch what he
calls a special military operation in
Ukraine
later in response to the most recent
attack zelenski sent out a video message
bitter and to a difficult year
and a dark sign of what's to come
Sky News Kiev